accorder
si neptune possède votre désir
alors je l'apporterai sur le
côté
je chevauche un hippocampe dans votre eau
jusqu'à ce que nous entendions cassé dans
la nature
parce qu'il
y a toi dans tout ce
que je sais
si seulement je
pouvais te voir
ce rêve
ne serait pas
si difficile si
seulement je
pouvais te voir
ce rêve
serait
aussi très difficile oui
parce que
si les étoiles filantes vous font vous demander
alors je peindrai le ciel
toute la journée
afin que nous puissions prendre de la hauteur et voler ensemble
si seulement je
pouvais te voir
ce rêve
serait
si difficile
si seulement je
pouvais te voir
ce rêve
ne serait pas
si difficile dur ouais
toi et tout connu
parce que